I want to take people out of their heads
I want origins to inject people with a
sense of wonder origins is the journey
of humankind it's basically a show that
reinvents the sort of historical epic
from a modern perspective so through a
modern lens we look back at our origins
essentially how we became who we became
with episodes such as the origin of fire
and how that made us human or the origin
of war or the origin of medicine how
these were transformative pivotal events
in human history so essentially the
origins of what made us human if people
have seen brain games they're obviously
aware that I'm very passionate about
making complex ideas accessible and I
think when people watch origins they're
gonna recognize a lot of what they've
seen me doing on the web expanded into
long-form the idea is to help people
transcend the bin there's and done thats
of the adult mind the sense that we know
it all the sense that we've seen it all
the sense that we understand it all and
it's going to be like epic and explosive
and heady and it's gonna blow people's
minds
[Music]
[Music]